well Millicent I kept trying to figure
out something to after bridesmaids and a
year went by and we couldn't figure it
out and then she got identity thief and
I was really sad because I missed her
summer window and then she had to go
back to Mike and Molly after so I was
moping around and onto my desk drops his
thing called the untitled female buddy
cop comedy I read it I go oh my god this
is like the most amazing role for
Melissa and I was already told that
sandy was interested in playing the
other role so but it was basically eight
weeks from when i read that script when
we first started shooting the movie
because she was already up doing
identity thief all the agents were like
she can't do it like it's not enough
time she's got like five maybe six weeks
if she starts the day after she stopped
shooting that movie and she has to go
back to the show but I was I I'm not
won't take no for an answer so basically
we worked out the schedule where she
learns she flew and she loved the script
so much and loved the idea of working
with sandy and with me again so she flew
in the day she wrapped identity thief
came in that next morning to the camera
test the next day we were shooting she
we shot six weeks straight with her and
then the last three weeks she had to get
on a plane and fly to LA do Mike and
Molly and fly back on her days off and
do our large stuff while we shot you
know Sandy's solo stuff so I mean the
poor thing was literally ready to drop I
mean we've literally carried her off the
set for the last scene because you were
just exhausted but um she wanted to do
it and you know and you can't you she's
she's such a trooper and but I'm amazed
at this movie actually came together
Melissa we do a lot of improv with
Melissa you know but we never sorry
never do anything without a great script
and Katie really wrote this great script
and we worked and worked and worked it
to make sure that we have this great
base but the same time melissa is great
we kind of let her let her go but I
wanted to make sure that sandy wouldn't
be mismatched and Sandy's the first to
admit she's not a you know she's not
improv is not her number one skill and
so we did is like about a month before
we started shooting Katie Dippold and I
went and had a went down to Atlanta
where she where Melissa was shooting
identity thief and did a rehearsal with
her in sandy and what is we read through
the script and then and then I'll just
have them improv scenes just as the
characters and that's why I can see the
true personality come out and that's
where I can see where like both Sandra's
kind of instincts were the most
important thing for KD and myself was to
make sure that these were women
who were good at their jobs who weren't
bumbling you know they just had issues
within that you know Sandy's character
she's really good she's so good at her
job that she can't help but Brett brag
about it and just be sort of you know
hard on her compatriots and that's why
she's having a hard time the melissa is
just kind of a loner she's like working
with anybody else but she's she's good
at her job again you know the actresses
were very hung up like none of us wanted
you know i'm i have so many issues with
how women have been portrayed in comedy
over the years that you know i always
want to make sure you know you want to
have room for the movie funny so there
needs to be mistakes made and
vulnerabilities there and goofing up
occasionally but at the same time you
know I want to make sure that there is a
core of strength so it's not like antsy
ladies when they get a gun they break
their nail thank you ya know cuz I mean
you know I get I'm just tired of
watching these comedies these male based
comedies where I'll see a hilarious
woman I know not being funny because
they make her be mean you know which is
that like this kind of little boys image
of what women are which is you know they
show up they ruin a good time and mom
comes in and stuff that so you know it
this is I'm just if I do nothing else in
my career then get to work with funny
ladies and make them funny on screen
because there's but there's so much you
know we we have so far to go I'll never
see anything that I go like York that's
like completely off message for me we
just will have different ways of saying
it but I always trust I mean I you have
to trust the audience it's the same
reason why when you watch an election
results in the election night and
they'll go point five percent of the
polls precincts are in we're going to
call it it's because you get one
audience of 500 people is pretty
indicative of what you're gonna get from
the general public and I don't say them
in a bad way it just it's it's pretty
amazing it's a very you know
representative and so yes I you know
chuckles warm chuckles we take them out
you know but but again I wouldn't I
don't I my litmus s is high for what I
think is is offensive or whatever but
then also all throughout the the filming
process and throughout the writing
everything I you know there's so many
women around it from the cast to the
writers the producers you know I'm
surrounded by women basically I deputize
everybody to vet everything so everybody
knows call me on anything there's
anything I say like try this ladies if
they go like we wouldn't do that I'm
like
cool like the you know that's where you
get in troubles like I know how you
ladies think you would do this but
what's great isn't you go they go like
we wouldn't do that it was like well how
would you do it if I'm working with
really good comedy people they'll give
me a solution to go like that's awesome
and then I can put my bend on it and we
all kind of way in and then we'll find
kind of the funniness funniest way to do
it but it's a democracy in that way to
sit in the back of a theater in a test
screening and here audiences laughing I
mean you know we put together
bridesmaids and like you know and Maya
Rudolph's walking Oh sinking in the
street with her in her wedding dress and
like women are screaming with laughter
it was just like that is so exciting for
me also because it's like we're finally
like women are kind of getting a comedy
that they are you know kind of enjoying
on that raucous level that that guys
have gotten for so long and so I just I
I love it so I'm so happy this happened
the way it did